you say sérieuses et bienvenue dans ce
nouvel épisode du coup de fil il ya
quelques mois où j'ai fait un coup de
fil un petit peu différent il s'agissait
d'une histoire c'était le mythe de
prométhée avec la vision de platon
d'ailleurs la vidéo est toujours
disponible
on peut la voir ici cette fois ci on va
parler une autre vision celle des yeux
d'un poète grec
on va parler du mythe de la boîte il ya
hyper longtemps les hommes et les dieux
vivaient ensemble en plus grand des cas
il n'y avait pas de mort pas de maladie
pas de vieillesse pas de faim pas de
soif
la nourriture poussait tout seul et a
pas de femmes aussi
bref tout allait plutôt bien jusqu'au
moment où il ya deux qui accède au
pouvoir suprême en défonçant chronos et
l'a26 et que ben c'est pas forcément
normal qu'ils aient les hommes et les
dieux qui vivent ensemble alors que les
hommes
ils sont clairement inférieurs du coup
ils appellent prométhée celui qui pense
avant saint tite ans et lui demande de
s'occuper du problème pour donner aux
hommes et aux dieux la place qui leur
correspond dans l'univers et savoir
quelle part leurs données dans l'ordre
cosmique prométhée sacrifie un boeuf et
va en faire deux parts dans la prière
paris va mettre des trucs sont pas très
comestible genre d eau et où il va
recouvrir sa d'une mince couche de
graisse à ces appétits centre et dans la
seconde par et à mettre de la bonne
viande bonnes pièces de chaque bouchée
et va recouvrir sa de trucs un peu
dégueu genre des boyaux et c est donc il
va faire choisir sa à 2 du coup en fait
ils essaient de tromper zeus et il a un
petit peu dans le camp des hommes quoi
sauf que 2,6 et tout donc c'est pas
hyper malin de la part de prométhée je
te conseille de faire attention 2 tout
laisse penser que j'ai un carré d'as
[ __ ] j'espère qu'il va se coucher
non mais je suis 2e set où enfin jeté
1,5 et 1,7
je sais quoi je là je tente le tout pour
le tout
ok on va peut-être me croire
je te dit tapie
architecte était con mais alors là il
est con on est d'accord t'es con c'est
complètement con alors on pourrait
croire que deux va prendre l'appareil à
la bonne viande mais non il fait exprès
et rendant le jeu de prométhée et
forcément il est pas content choquée
déçu quoi cette scène s'appelle le
partage de méconnaît et après ça dieu
s'il va vouloir se venger en punissant
les hommes alors qu'on avait quand même
rien à voir là dedans
en fait il valoir imposer le travail et
l'effort qu'ils sont quelque chose de
complètement nouveau pour eux par
exemple il va cacher la nourriture
j'aurai la pointe du blé il va le cacher
en mettant sous la terre perd le blesser
pas anodin c'est la nourriture qui à la
base du pain et le pain c'est la
nourriture qui caractérise les hommes en
tant que tel parce que ni les dix ans
mangent ni les bêtes et zeus ne s'arrête
pas là et fait la même chose avec le feu
en lui confisquant aux hommes sans feu
c'est difficile de faire cuire du blé
pour obtenir du pain ou même difficile
de faire cuire la viande qui a offert
prométhée du coup prométhée qui sent mal
et veut se rattraper va prendre une
branche de fenouil et va les chercher un
petit bout du feu divin de 2 pour le
cacher dedans
en gros pour résumer on à prométhée qui
est un gros rebelles qui se fait prendre
par dieu et qui va ensuite prendre son
feu le mec est chaud chaud feu je tue la
loba nord il ensuite discrètement donné
le feu aux hommes qui ont pouvoir se
chauffer et faire cuire leurs aliments à
vannes où étaient contents ah bah ça
c'est sûr a depuis le début de
l'aventuré on enchaîne les galères on
nous a supprimé le blé la camdiac du feu
il vient bien sûr ça nous a reboostés
pour le sud de la voiture c'est sûr mais
sauf que zeus baas pas compliqué il sait
tout du coup ils découvrent ce café
prométhée et décide d'aller encore plus
loin dans la punition il convoqua
pistoles le dieu du feu et lui demande
de créer un mannequin de jeunes filles 1
basé sur une vierge avant ses noces est
fait à l'image de 3ds
athena lestat et artemis c'est pandore
et c'est une bombe
on lui donne la parure d'athéna couronne
majestueuse la parole pour qu'elle
puisse s'exprimer
et je cite le texte en choeur de chienne
et un tempérament de voleuse plus sympa
pour la première femme de la
civilisation et zeus l'offre aux hommes
en disant je cite elle sera le malheur
des hommes à mahler plein de beauté que
les hommes chérirons plus que tout bon
cadeau empoisonné qui fait zizir pour
l'instant prométhée celui qui réfléchit
avant ils voient le coup venir
et prévient son frère epiméthée celui
qui réfléchit après en lui disant bas si
jamais tu reçois un cadeau des dieux
sont méfiants et d'aia pandore qui
arrivent sur terre et toque à la porte
des primes était
il a fait rentrer et tombe amoureux
d'elle et se marie merci mec tu avais un
job alors la stupéfaction
alors depuis le début on enchaîne les
épreuves nous on s'est dit bon c'est un
rouge tu vas sortir au conseil nous
apporte quoi ça s'appelle une femme
apparemment bon j'ai vu des boeufs des
bestioles et tout ça j'ai jamais vu je
m'y attendais pas personne ne s'y
attendait sauf que pandore ne vient pas
seul sur terre
elle vient avec une joie qu'on a appelé
après une boîte qui est complètement
fermée et elle doit pas l'ouvrir elle
doit pas l'ouvrir du tout nocalou la
boîte il ya plein de petits trucs qui
s'envole et zeus lui demande de refermer
la boîte tout de suite en fait elle
vient de libérer tous les maux de la
terre
et alors elle joue pas au scrabble c'est
les mots mae x 1c la mort la maladie la
vieillesse la peur la douleur touche pas
à mon poste ce genre de choses mais il
reste au fond de la boîte
une seule chose l'espoir parfait moi je
sais pas quoi dire je suis dégoûté on
avait eu l'épreuve de confort la plus
simple fait juste prendre une boîte et
pas l'ouvrir et qu'est ce qu'elle fait
elle lourd
[ __ ] j'ai le seuil moi je voulais trop
voir le courrier des proches là en plus
ça fait une semaine tout le monde est
malade au camp je sais pas ce que c'est
c'est eh ben le fun ou alors ce qui est
intéressant dans cette histoire c'est
évidemment tout ce qu'il ya derrière et
c'est des points qui tourne autour de
pandore ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle fait
et ce qu'elle représente
d'abord ce qu'elle est c'est une femme
la première dans le monde des hommes
mais c'est une femme artificielle
il y avait d'abord les hommes et ensuite
il ya eu la femme donc sa présence sur
terre elle n'est pas aussi légitimes que
celles des hommes
et en plus c'est une femme qui a été
créé pour nuire aux hommes j'avoue que
là on touche un petit peu au sexisme de
nos amis grecs puisque c'est une femme
qui va pervertir le monde établi mais
c'est intéressant parce que ça donne
peut-être des pistes de réflexion sur la
vision de l'époque ensuite il ya ce
qu'elle fait elle libère tous les maux
de la boîte ou de la jarre sauf un
l'espoir
sauf qu'il s'agit pas réellement de
l'espoir comme on dit aussi souvent du
tout le mot qui est utilisé dans la
version initiale clp 1 et ça sera du
plus tôt par la tente où est dans
l'expectative
donc oui si c'est une bonne chose qu'on
attend ça sera de l'espoir si c'est une
mauvaise chose ça sent donc c'était et à
de gros contre sens là dessus c'est
peut-être l'aspect le plus terrible de
la punition de 2 c les scellés le pis
dans la jarre faire le laisser aux
hommes
il n'ya pas pire punition que d'espérer
ou d'attendre si on espère être en bonne
santé c'est qu'on l'ait pas c'est qu'on
est malade
ainsi on pétait la forme
pas besoin d'espoir du coup selon la
philosophie grecque mais aussi
bouddhiste par exemple l'espérance est
négatif donc on se retrouve dans un
monde qui envahit par tous les maux est
la seule ressource qu'on a c'est la
tente de les voir venir et l'espoir de
les éviter
ça craint le dernier point son pandore
c'est la durée des guerres aux présentes
elle a une apparence attractive divine
et elle abrite un fonds qui est mauvais
néfastes pour l'homme
1 le faux est caché dans le vrai et ça
paraît à différents moments du mythe
par exemple quand promettait une offre
les eaux est elle très belle enveloppe
ou alors quand il va chercher le feu
divin et le cash dans du fenouil toutes
les actions primordial de ce récit elle
joue sur le même levier distinguer
l'apparence du fonds est finalement dans
ce mythe il ya des choses qu'on retrouve
dans le vie quotidienne par exemple va
devoir gérer notre espérance entre
anxiété afin de ne pas trop souffrir et
ensuite savoir distinguer le vrai du
faux
malgré les apparences d'ailleurs sur ce
dernier point ça me rappelle une notion
des grecs on a déjà vu ensemble ça fait
qu'à los gatos 1 ce qui est bon et beau
eh ben ce mythe va complètement à
l'encontre de cette notion de cette
vidéo vous a permis de distinguer le
vrai du faux autour du mythe de pandore
et ben n'hésitez pas à passer le coup de
fil un ami on se retrouve dans quelques
jours pour une nouvelle vidéo
le projet coûte il sera de la philo pur
donc une notion de philo pure et parmit
d'ici là je vous envoie du love et de la
piste yanina
merci pour tous vos retours sur la
dernière vidéo
heureux de voir que tu imagines si c'est
un programme qui nous plaît aussi
même s'il est très différent du reste de
la chaîne parce que j'ai pas forcément
comme je l'aï déjà dit dans un but
d'apprentissage pure mais plutôt un
moment' schiele qu'on passe ensemble
donc c'était vachement plaisir
classement un gros merci encore une fois
au type heures pour soutenir le projet
ça fait vachement plaisir
vous êtes comme ça merci